.
IT'S SUCH AN HONOR TO HAVE YOU
ON WITH US THIS AFTERNOON.
AND I'M JUST CURIOUS, YOU WROTE
THIS LAST WEEK, AND SURELY,
BEFORE THE MIDTERM ELECTION, HE
WROTE THIS, USUALLY, A VOTE IS
ABOUT A POLICY, TAX, OR
IMMIGRATION REFORM.
THIS YEAR'S VOTE IS ABOUT MORE
THAN THAT.
IT'S ABOUT WHETHER ELECTED
REPUBLICAN OFFICIALS WILL OBEY
THE LAW, FAIRLY COUNT THE VOTES
IN 2024, AND OBEY THE WILL OF
THE PEOPLE.
WHAT IS YOUR REACTION, AS WE
SIT HERE THIS WEEKEND, AND YOU
HAVE GOOD AMERICAN CITIZENS
SITTING IN ELECTION OFFICES IN
NEVADA AND ARIZONA, JUST DOING
THE WORK OF ENSURING THAT THAT
VOTES ARE COUNTED, THEY ARE
TABULATED CORRECTLY, THAT IS
ACCURATE COUNTS ARE GETTING OUT
TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
AND THIS IS HOW IT'S SUPPOSED
TO WORK.
IT'S KIND OF COMFORTING TO SEE,
YOU KNOW, ALL THIS HOLD UP OVER
THE LAST WEEK OR SO, DESPITE
EVERYTHING THAT'S HAPPENED IN
THIS COUNTRY.
>> YEAH, COMFORTING IS THE
RIGHT WORD, REASSURING, AND
ALSO, ALWAYS A REMINDER HOW
IMPORTANT THIS IS, AS
WELLINGTON SAID, AT WATERLOO,
IT'S THE CLOSEST THING YOU EVER
SAW IN YOUR LIFE.
AND SO, ONE OF THE THINGS WE
ALWAYS HAVE TO REMEMBER IS THAT
IN A DEMOCRACY, WE HAVE TO WIN
BATTLES, AND THE WAR GOES ON,
WHICH THE WAR IS,
METAPHORICALLY SPEAKING, THE
WAR IS KEEPING A SYSTEM WHERE
WE CAN PRESERVE THE RULE OF LAW,
WHERE WE CAN PRESERVE THE
CAPACITY TO GIVE AS WELL AS TO
TAKE.
AND DEMOCRACY IS VERY
COUNTERING TO IT, RIGHT?
WE ARE BASICALLY BUILT TO TAKE
WHAT WE WANT, TO SECURE OUR OWN
CELLS, OUR OWN DESTINIES, WHEN
IN FACT WHAT A DEMOCRACY DOES
IS IT CREATES A CAPACITY FOR US
TO HAVE THAT OPPORTUNITY BY
RECOGNIZING, BY RECOGNIZING
THAT YOUR EQUALITY, INDIGNITY,
I WAS PROTECTING.
YOU ARE MORE LIKELY TO
RECOGNIZE THE MINDS.
IF I RECOGNIZE THAT YOUR VOTE
COUNTS, YOU ARE MORE LIKELY TO
RECOGNIZE THAT MY VOTE COUNTS.
AND SO, I FEEL THAT, A LOT
BETTER, ABOUT THE FUTURE, THE
PRESIDENT AND THE FUTURE OF
AMERICAN DEMOCRACY ON THIS
SATURDAY THAN I DID LAST
SATURDAY.
>> WERE YOU SURPRISED AT ALL BY
THE RESULTS FOR?
YOU SEE, ELECTION DENIERS
RUNNING FOR SECRETARY OF STATE,
FOR EXAMPLE, IN KEY
BATTLEGROUND STATES, BEING
UNSUCCESSFUL.
YOU ARE SEEING CANDIDATES LIKE
MEHMET OZ, LISA ELDON, AND THE
NEW YORK GOVERNOR'S RACE, TUTOR
DICKSON IN MICHIGAN'S GOVERNOR
RACE, THEY CONCEDED.
YES, THEY WERE TRUMP BACKED
CANDIDATES.
THEY HAD HARD-FOUGHT RACES BUT,
THEY ULTIMATELY CONCEDED,
UNLIKE THE FORMER PRESIDENT.
I WANT TO PLAY WITH DEMOCRATIC
CONGRESSMAN TIM RYAN SAID, WE
LOST HIS ELECTION FOR SENATE
SEAT IN OHIO TO J.D. VANCE.
I'M GONNA GREAT REALLY FAST AND
I'LL GET YOUR REACTION.
>> I HAVE THE PRIVILEGE TO
CONCEDE THIS RACE TO J.D. VANCE,
BECAUSE THE WAY THIS COUNTRY
OPERATES IS THAT WHEN YOU LOSE
ON ELECTION, YOU CONCEDE.
>> NOT EVERYBODY IS DOING THIS,
BUT OUT IN ARIZONA RIGHT NOW,
IT DOESN'T SEEM TO BE HAPPENING
JUST YET WITH BLAKE MASTERS.
BUT CANDIDATES CONCEDING
GRACEFULLY, AND SHOWING CLASS,
AFTER EVERYTHING THAT WE'VE
BEEN THROUGH, IT'S ALMOST LIKE
A BOMB ON THE COUNTRY.
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
DOES IT SURPRISE YOU?
>> I THINK THAT'S RIGHT.
I THINK, YOU KNOW, ONE OF MY
ARGUMENTS ABOUT AMERICAN
HISTORY AND AMERICAN REALITY IS
THAT THERE WAS NEVER A ONCE
UPON A TIME, AND THERE'S NEVER
GONNA BE A HAPPILY EVER AFTER,
BECAUSE THIS IS A HUMAN
UNDERTAKING.
IT HAS TO DO WITH OUR HABITS OF
HEART AND MIND.
IT HAS TO DO WITH HUMAN FRAILTY,
AND OUR FOLLOW NATURE'S, AND
JUST TRYING TO GET JUST ENOUGH
RIGHT.
AND THAT'S WHAT AMERICA IS AT
ITS BEST, RIGHT?
JUST ENOUGH OF US DO THE RIGHT
THING, JUST ENOUGH OF THE TIME,
THAT WE KEEP THIS EXPERIMENT
AND THE JOURNEY TOWARD A MORE
PERFECT UNION GOING.
AND I THINK WHAT IS SO
UNSETTLING, AND YOU WERE AT A
FRONT ROW SEAT OVER THE LAST
FIVE YEARS OR SO, WITH THIS
NOTION THAT PERHAPS, JUST
ENOUGH OF US WEREN'T GONNA SHOW
UP ANYMORE.
AND THAT APPETITE AND AMBITION,
THE APPETITE AND AMBITIONS OF
ONE INTEREST, ONE PARTY, ONE
PERSON WILL GO INTO TRIUMPH
OVER WHAT AMERICAN POLITICS
OUGHT TO BE, WHICH IS AN
ATTEMPT TO WIN ELECTIONS,
CREATE SOLUTIONS TO GIVEN
PROBLEMS, FOR A GIVEN PERIOD OF
TIME.
AND THEN, DOING IT ALL AGAIN.
THAT'S WHAT POLITICS IS.
IT CAN'T BE TOTAL WAR EVERY
AFTERNOON.
IT CAN'T BE TOTAL WAR BY
ELECTION.
IT HAS TO BE A MEDIATION OF
DIFFERENCES.
AND I THINK PRESIDENT BIDEN'S
VICTORY IN 2020 WAS THE FIRST
GREAT ACT IN THIS DRAMA OF
TRYING TO CREATE A LONGER LEASE
ON LIFE FOR THIS EXPERIMENT.
AND I THINK IN MANY WAYS, 2022
WILL STAND AS ANY REALLY
IMPORTANT ONE TERM ELECTION, AS
IMPORTANT, REALLY, AS ANY I CAN
THINK OF.
YOU KNOW, HECK, ABRAHAM LINCOLN
LOST FUNCTIONAL CONTROL OF THE
HOUSE OF REPRESENTATIVES IN THE
MIDDLE OF A CIVIL WAR.
PRESIDENTS AND INCUMBENT
PARTIES USUALLY GET CLOBBERED
TO SOME DEGREE OR ANOTHER.
>> RIGHT.
>> AND INTERESTINGLY, PRESIDENT
BIDEN HERE HAS DEFIED HISTORY.
AND WHAT IT REALLY IS, THOUGH,
AND I WANT TO SAY THIS IN A
PARTISAN WAY, I AM NOT A
PARTISAN.
AS YOU SAY, PRESIDENT BIDEN IS
MY FRIEND.
I HELPED HIM WHEN I CAN.
BUT I HELP HIM, AND I BELIEVE
IN WHAT HE IS TRYING TO DO,
BECAUSE HE BELIEVES IN THIS
CONSTITUTIONAL EXPERIMENT.
AND YOU CAN DISAGREE ABOUT HIS
VIEWS ON TAXES OR CLIMATE, OR
WHATEVER YOU WANT TO DISAGREE
ABOUT.
THAT'S FINE.
THAT'S WHAT YOU'RE SUPPOSED TO
DO, TO USE THE PHRASE YOU USED
A MINUTE AGO.
BUT YOU CAN'T ARGUE ABOUT THE
FUNCTIONAL REALITY OF THE RULE
OF LAW.
AND THE RULE OF LAW, I THINK,
WAS ON THE BALLOT LAST WEEK.
AND I THINK IT ONE.
AND THAT DOESN'T MEAN WE CAN
TAKE THAT FOR GRANTED.
BUT LET'S BE HONEST, WE ARE
GONNA BE GETTING A TOTALLY
DIFFERENT CONVERSATION, IF
THESE DENIERS HAD ONE.
THEY LOST, AMERICAN DEMOCRACY
WON.
AND LET'S GET BACK TO ARGUE
ABOUT MARGINAL CLIMATE, AND NOT
ARGUING ABOUT REALITY ITSELF.
>> YEAH, I MEAN, THAT WOULD BE
MUSIC TO MY EARS.
I MEAN, THAT WAS MY GREAT FEAR
OVER THE LAST FOUR, FIVE YEARS,
JON, AND THAT'S WHY I'M SUCH A
BIG FAN OF YOUR WORK.
IT JUST FELT LIKE THINGS WERE
COMING UNGLUED.
AND COMING APART AT THE SCENES.
WE ARE JUST GETTING TO A POINT
WHERE WE, NOT JUST RESPECTING
FACTS AND TRUTH AND THAT SORT
OF THING, BUT ELECTIONS.
YOU KNOW, WE ARE GOING FROM THE
ALTERNATIVE OF FACTS TO THE
ALTERNATIVE OF ELECTION
RESULTS.
I THINK IT WAS HAPPENING BACK
IN 2020.
AND THIS TIME, TO YOUR POINT
ABOUT PRESIDENT BIDEN, I WANT
TO ASK YOU ABOUT THIS, BECAUSE
YOU WERE JUST ALLUDING TO THIS.
HISTORICALLY, AS YOU WERE
SAYING, YOU KNOW, PRESIDENT
STRUGGLE.
THE PARTY IN POWER STRUGGLES
DURING A MIDTERM, AND PRESIDENT
BIDEN'S APPROVAL RATING WAS IN
THE 40S, THE ECONOMY WAS
GETTING LOW MARKS FROM VOTERS.
PEOPLE COULD LOOK AT THE HIGH
GAS PRICES DOWN THE STREET, AND
YET, HE WAS -- PRESIDENT BIDEN
WAS ABLE TO BUCK ALL OF THAT.
DEMOCRATS WERE ABLE TO BLOCK
ALL OF THAT.
WHY DO YOU THINK THAT OCCURRED?
>> I THINK THE ARGUMENT ABOUT
DEMOCRACY, WHICH I BELIEVE IN
FERVENTLY, WAS THIS POSITIVE,
IF NOT -- I'M NOT SURE HOW MANY
PEOPLE WERE VOTING SOLELY ON
DEMOCRACY, BUT IT WAS PART OF A
MATRIX OF CONCERNS.
IT IS REALLY HARD IN THE
AMERICAN EXPERIENCE, IF YOU
THINK ABOUT IT, TO TAKE AWAY
SOMEONE'S RIGHT.
OUR STORY IS ABOUT THE
EXPANSION OF RIGHTS.
IT IS ABOUT WIDENING THE
MAINSTREAM.
IT IS ABOUT INCREASING
INDIVIDUAL AUTONOMY, SO THAT WE
CAN FULFILL THE DECLARATION OF
INDEPENDENCE THAT WE ALL ARE
CREATED EQUAL, RIGHT?
IF YOU THINK ABOUT CIVIL RIGHTS,
WOMEN'S RIGHTS, WORKERS RIGHTS,
THAT'S THE STORY OF THE COUNTRY.
AND IN OUR BEST MOMENTS OF THE
MOMENTS, WHERE WE HAVE EXPANDED
THE CAPACITY OF PEOPLE TO
DETERMINE THEIR OWN DESTINY'S
WITHIN THE CONSTITUTIONAL
STRUCTURE, AS OPPOSED TO
LIMITING THEM.
AND I THINK IN THE SUPREME
COURT, WHEN THEY OVERTURNED ROE
VERSUS WADE, AND SAID IN THE
OPINION, IT'S A POLITICAL
ISSUE.
WELL, YOU KNOW WHAT?
WE HAVE SOMETHING OF A VERDICT
ON THAT NOW, NO?
>> RIGHT.
>> NOT JUST, IT'S BEEN AROUND
THE COUNTRY.
AND WITH THE ELECTION DENIAL IS
ABOUT IS TAKING AWAY OUR RIGHT
TO CHOOSE OUR LEADERS.
AND SO, PEOPLE, AMERICANS,
DON'T LIE.
AND THEY DON'T EVEN RECOGNIZE
IT AT A CONSCIOUS LEVEL.
THEY DON'T LIKE THE IDEA OF
LOSING THE AUTONOMY AND CEDING
AUTHORITY TO TEMPORARY
MAJORITIES OR ONE PARTY OR
ANOTHER.
THAT'S THE GREATEST OF THE
AMERICAN EXPERIENCE, RIGHT?
WE DON'T HAVE A CULTURE OF
TOLERANCE.
BECAUSE TOLERANCE SUGGESTS, AND
THIS IS A LITTLE DORKY FOR YOU
ON A SATURDAY AFTERNOON -- BUT
YOU ASKED.
>> THAT'S RIGHT, LAY IT ON US.
>> SO TOLERANCE, IF YOU THINK
ABOUT IT, THIS WAS AMAZONIAN
ARGUMENT WAY BACK.
RELIGIOUS TOLERANCE, FOR
INSTANCE, IS A LITTLE TRICKY.
BECAUSE IF YOU TOLERATE, THAT
PRESUPPOSES THAT THERE IS A
MAJORITY THAT IS GRANTING A
RIGHT FOR A MINORITY TO DO
SOMETHING, RIGHT?
YOU A TOLERATE.
IF YOU CHANGE THE PRISON A
LITTLE BIT, AND THINK OF IT AS
LIBERTY, THAT IS NOT RELIGIOUS
TOLERANCE, BUT RELIGIOUS
LIBERTY, THEN LIBERTY ISAACMAN
SENT.
NOBODY CAN TAKE AWAY YOUR
LIBERTY.
TOLERANCE COMES AND GOES.
AND AT THE CORE OF THE AMERICAN
INSIDE IS THAT WE ARE FREE
PEOPLE.
AND THAT APPLIES TO OUR HEALTH
CARE DECISIONS.
IT APPLIES TO OUR DECISIONS
ABOUT HOW WE WANT TO MAKE A
LIVING, HOW WE WANT TO RAISE
OUR FAMILIES, AND WHO WE WANT
TO VOTE FOR.
AND I THINK THAT THAT
SENSIBILITY WAS VERY MUCH IN
THE COUNTRY.
IT'S BEEN MANIFESTED IN THE
VOTE.
AND I THINK THAT A LOT OF WHAT
WE DO FOR A LIVING, A LOT WOULD
OF OUR FRIENDS DO FOR A LIVING,
YOU KNOW, WE NEED TO LOOK YET
AG